a few versions of batman's sidekick
robin have appeared in live-action films
but there are a lot more we've still yet
to see which one might best fit into the
universe of the batman keep watching for
the answer when director matt reeves of
batman premieres in the us on march 4th
2022 it will mark the first stand-alone
live-action batman movie since
christopher nolan's the dark knight
rises in 2012. robert pattinson will be
donning the cow he'll be teaming up with
zoe kravitz as catwoman and they'll be
taking on a whole host of threats
there's paul danos the riddler a zodiac
killer inspired take on the character
who's trying to expose gotham's elites
there's also colin farrell as the
penguin and john taturo as a gangster
carmine falcone batman will luckily get
a little moral support from bruce
wayne's longtime butler alfred
pennyworth played by andy circus as is
always the case with a new batman movie
one big question is whether robin will
be part of the story unfortunately for
fans of batman's stalwart sidekick robin
isn't in the mix this time though reeves
hasn't ruled him out in the future holy
heartbreak so far robin has shown up
just a few times in live-action movies
he was played by douglas croft and
johnny duncan in the often forgotten
batman movie serials in the 1940s and
bert ward played robin in the 1966
live-action batman film alongside adam
west chris o'donnell played him in both
1995's batman forever and 1997's batman
and robin like crafton ward's robins
this was the dick grayson version of the
character a traveling acrobat whose
family is tragically killed the dark
knight rises had an original character
with similarities to robin john blake
who was played by joseph gordon-levitt
he's a gotham city cop who works for the
batman and later reveals you should use
your full name i like that name
robin
thanks that leaves a slew of dc comics
versions of robin that may have shown up
on tv and in animated productions but
have never appeared in a live-action
film pattinson told collider he's up for
adding robin with conditions yeah but he
has to be 13. that's the only way i'll
accept it no i love death in the family
and stuff but i think it'll be so cool
also people are so scared of it but it's
kind of exciting i think it would be a
really fun addition death in the family
is a 1988 comic story in which the jason
todd version of robin is killed by the
joker todd is an orphan and the second
individual to take up the robin mantle
after dick grayson aged out of it later
todd is resurrected as a vigilante
superhero red hood who unlike batman has
no moral qualms about killing criminals
adjacent todd arc including the
resurrection would seem to fit right in
with the dark tone reeves as
establishing with the batman there's
also the third robin tim drake he's a
third iteration of robin who after
figuring out both batman and robin's
real identities approaches bruce wayne
and asked to become his next sidekick
bruce trains drake into one of the best
martial artists and detectives in the
world drake eventually ages out of the
role too after which she takes on a new
name red robin if reeves really wanted
to throw a curveball he'd go with the
stephanie brown version of robin she's a
street vigilante and the daughter of the
super villain cluemaster who starts her
career as a costumed hero spoiler she
briefly claims a robin mantle but is
fired for disobeying orders she later
becomes bad girl or there's a fifth and
most recent robin damien wayne bruce
wayne's son with talia al gore since
talia appeared in the dark knight rises
and had a brief relationship with bruce
and since the batman is a wholesale
reboot of the franchise this one seems
less likely there's also carrie kelly
from frank miller's the dark knight
returns who spent some time as robin in
a version of batman's very late career
it's also entirely possible that reeves
could follow nolan and go with something
new before he can do that the batman
must first deliver at the box office the
good news is the critics mostly love it
so far
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the batman are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one